hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Katie Dubois
we're gonna check out the official
trailer for before we go
a lot of people have been asking me to
watch this trailer it's a romance
starring Chris Evans as you guys know is
the actor who's in the hunger games
mockingjay and all the other Hunger
Games you know mm-hmm I'm just doing
that piss people off I know the Chris
Evans is and come on people I guarantee
they're still gonna be coming some
people be like [ __ ] idiots for brief
strong language [ __ ] I feel that we met
in Grand Central for arena we were meant
to find each other enjoy there
sure you're okay my person is silver you
got like 80 bucks how far you going you
can't open it so what do you want to do
you want to get a hotel room or
something excuse me
oh not not not for us for you we can
find your purse we can get you home and
make me a hero man you're already a hero
cap I'm sure that my husband will really
appreciate your helping me I think you
might be missing some hardware what's
that supposed to mean
about where I'm wedding ring no I'm
calling it like I see it Oh go back to
whatever you were doing before I came
along and I ruined your night you didn't
ruin my night I like your shiny trumpet
I bought it with a shiny engagement
all we need is a time machine let's try
its buh-buh-buh-buh what would you tell
yourself just skip me off all together
then you wouldn't admit me I still
haven't decided if that's a good thing
I'm just kind of feeling somebody who's
gonna play a major part in your life
yeah
it's possible that you can meet somebody
who's perfect for you even though you're
committed to somebody else 11 love sucks
that is so depressing
how can one of the worst nights in my
life also be one of the best
do you know the most interesting thing
about hotel art it's what's the on the
back god hookers are here
you probably shouldn't touch anything in
this room Chris Evans directed it or did
I read that wrong Chris Evans directed
it cool cool
surprising went for that kind of story
to direct it interesting very
interesting
it looks really sweet I mean what it
really comes down to are these two
actors gonna like that's a that could
always save a romantic movie like How to
Lose a Guy in 10 days not the greatest
movie but we're really saved it was
their chemistry in that movie so I
always feel that when it comes to a
romance movie if the two main actors
that we're supposed to feel the romance
for the chemistry's really felt the
movie is still enjoyable I think they
have the twinkle in their eye that it's
Michael in there I'm pretty sure Chris
Evans wants the [ __ ] okay like the big
one yeah that's really the underlying
feeling behind all this is the sexual
animal instincts okay yeah sure that's
what the film is really exploring do you
remember when aha when he said you make
me some kind of hero and I said you
already are cap yeah that was the best
part of the reaction that was the best
part of the react are we going over our
reaction yeah I'd rather review our
reaction then review the trailer okay I
thought you did a nice job yeah I was
really into it yeah you were really
watching I was really late at my guard
down letting myself feel like this
cheesy emotion yeah it was good feel
good I'm glad
yeah how do you feel um how did I feel I
felt it was anyone where you were in the
room was so pulled in I know yeah I feel
good I feel good I wasn't sure what to
expect at first like my first 10 seconds
I was like oh is this just gonna like
train station like great central love
story but I actually liked that she kind
of had like this attitude like you're
not gonna fix my night buddy yeah like
my nights [ __ ] and she kind of kept
that and she really had to be like won
over by this guy star
and so I was I was yeah that sounds like
a healthy way to start off their
romantic relationship always like
something like that like one or two
people like yeah I'm available and I'm
happy and I'm looking for true love and
here it is but here's the thing are they
gonna end up together in the end because
she's not from New York it seems like so
are they gonna have this beautys one
that beard though he looks cool he looks
cool looks good with the beard good I
like the beard yeah he makes him look
sexier I wish Captain America would have
a beard that's the thing though the
sermon isn't allowing to grow a beard my
[ __ ] Avengers jokes are so funny he's
goddamn phone it's your goddamn phone
answer it and Alice Eve though is
gorgeous Oh beautiful oh so fragile
mesmerizing yeah mesmerizing so you say
fresh yeah fresh well she's not she's
not like covered in makeup she's not
like like yeah she's just sort of like
clean and available I would say fresh
for that I wish she's clean and fresh
you know what I mean mm-hmm she is yeah
we can still we were talking about the
same thing I feel like I can make that
assumption about her the movie does sit
still doesn't look like it's breaking
any new ground though for a romantic
movie it's kind of like come on how many
like this is like one of those indie
romance flicks you can be a little bit
more daring yeah I don't know the
trailer doesn't give me enough to to
feel like I have an assumption about
that yeah I'm gonna what I'm gonna see
this movie I think I'll see this movie
I'll probably see you Tim we're
interested because he's directing it
that is sure how do you direct yourself
well it's it's a special skill we have
special skill we have if you need the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Katie's
channel Katie du Bois by the way guys
are going to VidCon this weeks off I'm a
little late on uploads like if a video
drops or something and that is why and
you can follow
Katie and I on Facebook and Twitter I
have an Instagram vine periscope Marcus
Lumi great movie reviews can you give me
a shout out thanks Marcus Lumi Marcus
Lumi is a type of [ __ ] that Katie
likes to give to people actually that's
incorrect
no it's fully factual she will actually
go upside down and then stick her tongue
out then bite her tongue and then roll
it do I get to sexualize you know that's
an affront Katie I have a little
girlfriend yeah boy proven Marcus
looming you're a good guy you are not a
[ __ ] maneuver Fergie